الظرف ذاته والطريق ربما مسيره النزوح عن
الديار تتلاقى تفاصيلها عالميا جلب ما
تيسر لهم ووسيله نقل ان توفرت
اعداد النزوح وصلت مداها عام عام 2022
وتخطط واحدا وسبعين مليونا في رقم قياسي
جديد
ازمه تتبع اخرى عام فتح ذراعيه اما للحرب
او الكوارث الطبيعيه العاملين الاساسيين
لزياده اعداد الفارين
ارتفاع بنسبه 20% بعد هجره جماعيه ضربت
اوكرانيا في حربها بلغ عددهم 17 مليونا
وايضا فيضانات باكستان اغرقت البلاد
بثمانيه ملايين نازح داخليا
العام الماضي ولا ثقيلا على افريقيا
الصراعات المتتاليه ضاعفت اعداد المغتربين
قصرا افريقيا جنوب الصحراء الاكثر تضررا
وصلت اعدادهم الى 16 مليون و500 الف شخص
عشر دول اخرى يرزخ فيها ثلاثه ارباع
الفرين داخليا ابرزها سوريا وافغانستان
واليمن واثيوبيا وفق تقرير مشترك لمنظمات
امميه
عداد الفرين لن يتوقف وفق تقديرات امميه
هم متقارب ينتظرون فرجا لن ياتي قريبا
ربما في عام حالي بصراعات متفاقمه غذاء
السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات